hello went welcome to this video yeah
this is the final video to cover them
candidates tournament 2016 yet today we
had the final round and have not yet
made a video on round 30 in the
penultimate round so I decided to just
make one video for the finishing two
rounds yeah let's start with the games
in round 13 I will still look at all of
the games but I will focus on the games
that decided ultimately who will
challenge the world champion later this
year so i'm starting with round 13 and
go with to pile of nakamura first this
game has no relevance whatsoever for the
qualification spot so as to paula zahn
minus 40 and the camera on minus one
before this game they Yannick Arab
fights for maybe getting back at fifty
percent but for the part of this
tournament is already disaster um okay
we have a Queens gambit declined to part
of phone is playing them yeah or all
opening moves as we know but with
Nakamura it's interesting he has a wide
opening repertoire in recent years
however he switched to really playing
very classical very solid openings with
black he played lots of Dutch defenses
and Kings Indian and so on and this is
it seems a thing of the past and now he
plays Queens gambit sandy 45s it
actually served him very well in in
recent years the tournament results have
been excellent in this event however
sometimes had the impression that he was
a little bit too yeah a little bit yeah
to solid in a way in some situations
okay we have the classical Queens gambit
Bishop have formed castles and now a 3
by 2 pallav this is an interesting
sideline on the ideas that this is a
normal movie 3 and then black
normally going for night bd7 nowadays
and white players struggle to get
something we've seen some of that in the
event as well and to Panos idea with a
three years that if black holes not bd7
now he has this additional option of
playing not to be five the idea is that
c6 is bad because this is winning
material winning the exchange so black
has to go 98 and then after e3 and to
maybe see 693 we have yeah a different
position to what we usually see in the
in this line yeah black usually now
tries to play something with f5 and it's
just a different position but nakamura
went c5 this move is of course also
possible black now switches back to the
c5 plans where he's also theoretically
speaking okay it's just in recent years
ned beatty seven was more popular to
part of now plays very surprisingly
actually the non-linear screen to see to
this is the most popular move by far
after which Queen a5 rook to e1 this
nowadays the the most topical I'm this
for example had been played in last
year's Sinfield cup and San Luis between
cars and with white and a camera black
so and like a more hands experience with
this kind of line yeah to part of
forever captures on d5 and this is quite
uncommon as it is not believed to give
white anything after it takes this is an
important move actually this is better
than Knight takes Knight takes is of
course possible it's not a bad move but
this is just transposing to a different
line where the normal verdict is that
yeah why does maybe having a slight very
slight advantage
it's something that I've played quite a
bit by a different move on as I said and
I think in this position it takes is
stronger because black here is ready to
play deform and if you can get rid of
your iqp while opening up the position
you should be in very decent shape with
black then amazing thing is that now to
pawn off is not really doing anything
against it and place before this is it
seems already yeah quite inaccurate um
okay he does not have any advantage here
but he can try to at least be equal with
the with a move like Bishop e2 it is
very meager like goes deform but still I
think it's better than before after
before Nakamura immediately fired with
deform yeah and this is also very
standard what else is there you won't
retreat with the bishop d 4 is a lot
stronger yeah now to part of decided to
take after long think it's really a bit
weird that he had to think here on move
10 problem is also after takes between a
5 this position is not very attractive
for YTM he has to allow this and yeah
it's just so good what can you say this
is going to form okay each plate this
and I mean okay black is more
comfortable now but it's not necessarily
bad for white an interesting thing by
the way is the move Knight to a for this
is something that I also looked at which
should be seven is good now and after
etx 925 this is a position where white
is really playing with fire something
like this is a very funny line and wear
white cannot take on before because that
leads into in two million
disaster check check and yeah something
like that is going to be a very quick
end to this game yeah white white is
really in a bit of trouble here so what
he did I think is relatively Bassam
capture here and now Knight takes Queen
takes is bad in a count of on account of
this canceling long let's move sometimes
for easily forgotten because white and
spread is a three before and putting the
King somewhere here does not look very
natural but here it is very strong as it
gets the King out of the e-file quick
here to attack the night so night XD for
was stronger yeah um Bishop b3 now by
the power of he forces the Queen trade
like this and to Bishop e2 now yeah this
is not another happy move but you would
love to keep that vision but where are
you going with this if you go to c5 v6
is direct reputation and well here black
has a five for example it's just losing
even more time so we should be two is
relatively best yeah now my camera took
that and now it's better due to the
better porn structure you played Nagi
form directly attacking this pawn & E
for now yeah also not a very happy move
by Dwight can definitely not afford to
take this would give black fantastic
play it's got the better minor piece
with the bishop and weaknesses to attack
so II form and here the thing is also
why it is seriously weakened ya black
ass those invasion ideas however from
here on to power of Defense quite well
it's not a nice position to play because
black is so active but he got this trade
in that was nice and also get some
activity with Roxy one yeah I want to
basically fast forward a little bit to a
critical position a bit later
now we see that black still maintains
this portal this is activity up to here
yeah and now he in this position black
is again is bad at right but what wide
should do now his tomb yeah to take him
this and probably play something
something along these lines where you
are where you are porn down but you can
fight this results a bit vulnerable this
porn and currently that passer area is
very far back not fun but it's what you
have to do to palo please hook a one or
ever found more active but this doesn't
seem to work at all night takes only
five and no after the check king of
seven it turns out that the black king
is totally safe first of all this Bishop
is hanging so white has to take care of
that a little bit played here and now g5
yeah black is this black is one pawn up
this is hanging and this this rook is
basically it's almost trapped so rugae
one was the totally gang goes that was
failing simply so yeah now there are
only a couple of mumbles after night f4
and it's a pile of resigned so he really
had a rotten avenge him very very bad
opening in this game when you are verse
after move 13 with white this is simply
not acceptable for the player who's been
in the top 10 for for ages um quite
weird he probably totally confused move
orders that's what I what I guess ok the
next game to check is on and geary from
the penultimate round if this game has
some relevance of course still for the
top places because I learnt got into
this round with a plus one score and
with the win what
yeah get back into the gap with leaders
with kawana and kayaking Giri is on
fifty percent at the chair 12 draws and
with a win against honored also would
have some remote chances left so it's a
game where both players actually yeah
should try to win I want to look at some
key moments of this game it's an Italian
game and we see this plan now the C 3 a
4 plan which is currently in fashion and
it's a new idea here by giving any
newest strong and 97 s not a new idea
but I think that actual move waters
pretty pretty nu into has not been seen
in this event yet it's 97 and now and
goes Bishop g5 this is an interesting
twist trying to yeah asking black let's
say do you want a double porn down on f6
it said something that bothers you yeah
the answer is no that just c6 was played
black also could have played 96 that was
certainly possible after which night h4
is a move that we looked at in the
broadcast yeah I did the broadcast on
Sunday together with grand master Rhonin
hearts we for the ICC and this is what
we were looking at and we concluded that
black is certainly okay here but give us
move c6 is also fine just ignoring
Bishop f6 I we think I think that this
capture is probably not leading to much
um Black has very good central support
and the nightie on a three it doesn't
look so brilliant here for the play
against any double points for example
night see two black and gold e5 and this
is not bad at all so let's see two
played by honored castles and night h4
are pre-empting any 96 yeah d5 now
played by kiri this is so again very
logical strike in the center
after decentralizing movement takes
takes pawn takes was possible but this
kind of porn center sometimes can again
can get vulnerable so this is an
intangible decision that's at least it's
clearly clearly a possible at good move
yeah now why does putting some pressure
on the e5 pawn and black ISM defending
this with Bishop g4 and after rook e8
the move d 4 is actually slightly
puzzling for black you don't want to
take yeah this is chang kind of keeps
giving white a little bit too much in
terms of peace activity so II for maybe
but then 95 whoops then 95 looks a
little bit tricky with maybe the bishop
coming around not that it's fantastic
for white but it looks like he's having
a little something this is why gear we
played Bishop g4 Bishop h4 now the
interesting point of this move is that
after age 3 black is going to h5 and the
movie for a sorry g4 is punished very
heavily by bayi form that's very nice
this is hanging but there's this is this
idea the check so after the capture 3g
three yeah why does chang losing
immediately quite funny and white can
resign the other mood chief is suicidal
and yeah another when Bishop h4 going
forward for this regrouping against the
e5 pawn however giri has to move Knight
f4 that's a good move putting pressure
on d3 yeah white cannot really allow
this night to stay on f4 for a long time
so it simply takes it and now goes
deform yeah this Bishop looks a little
bit dumb now but it immediately gets
activated will see 5
and here we see that black should be
okay in this position right doesn't have
any great move now taking as bad yeah
something like this this this is not
very nice and d5 is just strategically
wrong it makes this Bishop look very
stupid well this is getting activated
moves like 94 or group the aids to
attack this porn come to mind yeah I
don't had to be modest and play Bishop
e2 that's what he did and now we have
this position yeah Black has the bishop
pair and good a good pieces but white
has the better pawn structure yeah we
she can fast forward a little bit we
have those trades him Jay and now Bishop
f2 yeah actually hit this a little bit
too strong took too quickly i wanted to
kind of make a little bit of a show out
of that mood but giri really took on f
tonight yeah he had yeah he's got lots
of criticism in the internet on the
internet that he's played so many
drawers and i think this is only partly
justified they were like two or three
games maybe where he really played in a
very very modest fashion and not really
going for it but okay what about this he
just sacrifice no sacrifice on f2 um
yeah White has to take it check and it's
it's very much for us the other move 94
is punished with this so white has to go
back and now night age five threatening
mate yeah white only has one move to
continue here he played g4 and yeah what
was given idea he took now with the pawn
and this is the thing we again ever made
thread with black and this night is
close to joining the action it seems
that if you look at all this with the
help of an engine
that gives sacrifice is not entirely
correct and it seems that rock deform is
the as the move to to prove that how
does that how does that work group
deform maybe Luke ce8 is the relatively
best move if black captures him Knight
takes then why this is a lot better yeah
one from point is that this night is
hanging so if green takes d4 for example
for that for the tactic why can actually
just take there is no problem whatsoever
the queen is covering this and leg is
very unhappy about the night being
traded because the night with no
therefore has some kind of source for
counter play yeah rupee eight is maybe
the best tribe and after that probably
85 is the best move and what is better
here yeah i mean it's it's still a game
that has to be played and I'm very
certain that the practical chancer said
black him has a pretty pretty
substantial I mean the white king is in
danger objectively speaking though I
think white is clearly better when the
engine gives a win basically one point
for something like that but it's a
different matter if you ask a computer
or led to humans playing time travel I
think it was a still a very brave
decision by giving to sacrifice the
peace and in some way it paid off
because I now played Bishop d3 it didn't
play rugby for after this move I think
black is close to having full
compensation or probably ask for
compensation it's rather difficult to to
get to grips with this position um yeah
okay first of all g2 is the threat so 94
is played closing that diagonal and down
g6 covering the f5 square and Queen f6
black does not have something very clear
in terms of yeah
threat threat threat he's just yeah
keeping this this dangerous position
with the night and the pawn it's very
difficult for y to coordinate and
ultimately decided to play Bishop f3 and
this is actually returning some material
check check and check so there's an
exchange that leg one but that night was
immensely immensely annoying so very
understandable decision by a former
world champion yeah b5 big stakes and
Queenie for let's take stock Black has
rook and pawn against the two minor
pieces but White has a wide open king
and the piece is currently on the white
side are not perfectly coordinated and
if we go ahead a couple of moves up to
up to this point here queen bee three
and this position is probably exactly
equal because it's kind of it's a fine
balance between the activity and black
attacking weaknesses and encounter play
against the king the way ana place now
is a bit risky but we have to understand
that he needs to win to get keep keeping
contention for the qualification spot
and he went 95 giving out that pawn it
seems that this ultimately also is just
a draw but yeah I mean it was difficult
to suggest something else he was just
going for it in a way gave up that porn
and now played Queen to f4 this is a
very risky winning tribe but
understandable given the tournament
situation the move knight c6 also looks
pretty good here intending night here
but black goes rupee eight right now can
play 97 for a nice for funny tactic but
after Luke takes the chair here this
will end in a draw as well I think Alan
certainly saw that line and decided to
play Queen air for two yeah put more
problems
it is however still nothing for white in
fact it's rather risky for white but
we'll see Queen a to covering himself
and now see for it closes that diagonal
yeah give you place that well it plays
Queen 879 check King age two digs and
Bishop d5 that was what island was was
was hoping for probably when he played
played into that line and yeah we come
out to a critical position now after the
next move the position is immediately
equal and also it's kind of clear that
it is that it is equal in a way yeah
rook f8 ruka eight was played mmm we'll
see what happens after that but an
interesting move for suggested by
computers here is the move look c5 it it
might be that this is still a draw after
the move Queen to d4 it's a pretty
strong move setting up this pin one
point is that after Luke c7 here white
will probably hold a drawer without that
much difficulty it's still a bit
trickier one thing is you're in this pin
so the pawn cannot move and after King
g7 night f7 as possible as the king and
pawn ending here is a draw this is so
this is a draw it's a bond down but
still drawn and the thing that can be
tried as the following this and yeah
black of course now can continue this
position and try to make use of the fact
that those two pieces a kind of tied to
one another makes it somewhat awkward
yeah Brooks is seven for example white
has to go back here and now this and you
have to check and it really looks weird
but it seems that this is holding yeah
the computer doesn't find a winner at
least
which is pretty amazing it looks very
strange this kind of Bishop Knight
scenario but this is at least something
that black can try to play for a win
sorry another move that was interesting
was keen to g7 and were also possible
the move that give you played rukka 8
however is is a draw it really is a draw
due to ya Queen f6 I not know goes for
that he has no way of continuing the
game I mean he could have it can take
here but you're rather playing for lossy
area okay maybe you can still take on f7
here that's possible but there's really
no winning idea also with white so Queen
f6 advises the draw because night xj6 is
is the key idea so I give you a plate
the chick went back and King due to
attend a resided here basically okay
yeah idea jog weeds the idea is always
night takes 26 this is the thing so if
black let's say it goes back here and
okay he just went back and forth you to
cover the cover the checks um I just
want to show the drawing idea of how to
do that maybe you have to create or
something like that and the night f7
actually wins and wears a way to show
the draw this one man energy for
actually wins that's also problem yeah
like has to go to do those Queen moves
probably had the wise he loses even wow
yeah okay so there was an interesting
game actually give me really tried
something and it didn't yeah it didn't
quite work but he still could have
gotten probably very close to win if he
plays better in this in this critical
situation I mean the next game I want to
check is a roni on kayaking so this is
still very relevant for the top
standings as kayaking wasn't plus two
before that game well Aronian was back
on 50
and with the wind could entertain some
slight hope still now ok we have got c4
and this is again played and it's the d5
lines a reversed dragon Sicilian in line
that we only had seen once in this
tournament we had seen my farm or Bishop
before and this has a very solid
reputation so it was surprising to not
see that two off to a seated earlier um
okay Aronian with a different
interpretation in an earlier game
between smith lion give me we had seen
this before set up but Bishop e3 is of
course also possible what white is going
for here is to put something on c5
ideally yeah put a bishop their trade
bishops and then put in ideas blacks and
whites normal idea 95 Bishop t2 if
Bishop c5 here in this position then d 6
is pretty decent like us quite okay with
this kind of position v6 is not ideal
but it's not a big weakness anyway so
Bishop back a 5 and 95 man netting the
bishop pair a for Andrew p1 so what has
the two bishops which is certainly happy
about but they are not doing that much
yet white also has the B file so they
can detect something on b7 yeah blacks
position is rather rather solid though
it's not very exciting anything but
black is certainly yeah certainly not in
trouble I think in the upcoming part of
the game Aronian makes nice slow and
steady progress yeah he gets ass Bishop
a little bit more active the night comes
around III to cover the g four square
in night came to you for ya now night d5
was played and the bishop was secured
only one yeah this is a critical
position and to be perfectly honest I'm
still not one hundred percent sure about
the next next couple of moves to be
honest um yeah so one move that is
possible now and probably the most
obvious choice is to move c6 this was
not played by kayak inna think he
rejected probably on account of white
being able to sacrifice him this this is
pretty nice for white it's a full
exchange you don't even have a point at
the moment but it's a very strong light
and the whole coordination of the pieces
is pretty good also you have very good
chances to get one of the be pawns and
then even from material point of view
it's not so bad I understand that maybe
kayaking wanted to avoid that it looks a
bit awkward you have to play this
position with black he took on a three
year but this is a very risky decision
and possibly a bad one yeah aronian now
played a very interesting move c6
intermediate move taking the Queen and
black cannot take white screen as then
after seat XD 7 the position is
surprisingly bad for black there are
simply too many threats now coming first
of all the night is of course um
attacked on on v1 and if it escapes to
it's only available square then 95 is a
huge issue hangs Hanks 96 coing I mean
this is a disaster Oh Andrew k1 now this
is also trapping the night it's it's a
it's a it's really bad so that is not
possible at all after c6 in fact black
doesn't have yeah have a huge choice he
had to go to his cell which he did
having a look outside that strand
annoyed yeah Queen a2
attacking b7 attacking d5 so quite a
number of things hanging bc six is good
rook checks and Bishop cell now covering
the knight on d5 the whole position
looks very shake here that black has and
our own yard place the critical move
roxy five this breaks this diagonal it
detects the night but also at XD five um
yeah now um kayaking um yeah chooses a
very tactical way of doing this and
place Knight takes III it's a pretty
pretty hard decision to make the
alternative was night to be five in this
position it looks funny because white
can take but there is a point and ticks
ticks ticks and again i take c 3 opening
up this diagonal in in this position
after Queen to be 1 92 92 it's crazy in
a way but in this line jan and then king
g 2 and a 3 and I think White has a lot
better White has better winning chances
actually then we see in the end game in
the game it's kind of similar but here
there's a deep one stone and I think
this should should help yeah we have to
compare this with the later with the
later game this is what kayaking played
but here he's also under under huge in
huge trouble aronia not took the night
the alternative was to first capture 18
I will check and only then grab that
might thing is this is also not totally
clear not totally clear but it should be
better for wide and now there's night
situ and Nagi 2nite g2
King takes and now probably between 27
and to cover that dr. ook a five white
oaks Luke a five why this better I mean
Blackwell will struggle and then try try
as best but whitey is better and this is
at a better position then we reached in
the game the move night c 2 is not
helping as after I think Queen to see
one white is retaining this piece back
oops probably here and now King jf want
to cover cover the check yeah here why
does better he's a piece of for porn you
should not underestimate blacks
practical chances this is not so easy to
win as dear three is weak and the pieces
are uncoordinated and that a pawn can
become a force pretty soon a very
difficult phase of the game here but
roop takes b8 was probably the moment
here for aronia to get something
decisive he took on a three and now the
coming sequence is almost forced traded
and night takes g2 King takes and a
three now we see that the apron is the
source for counter play Queen to be
seven and Queen to d8 know at some very
strong play um $27 played yeah what else
is there not much yeah if you take with
the rook then Bishop g5 is actually
leading to a black advantage so Queens
the seven was played and now after the
trade and Bishop g5 and we get this
ending and the problem was that in this
ending it was very difficult here for
why to keep their deep on black God
Bishop Jaden and the rook was now coming
around we have seen another end game
earlier
they're white kept the DuPont here this
is not possible Black is invading and
attacking this pawn and you cannot keep
it absolutely cannot keep it so got this
and look back to the eighth yeah and I
think this is a draw it really is a draw
the pawn on a2 is supported from far
back from g8 white cannot regroup it's
night to just take the pawn and win it
it's really not possible and you have no
way of changing the pawn structure
favorably and this game actually now
from here on take 60 moves so I don't
want to analyze it that much that was
really i mean there were some some
little things that kayaking had to to
look at but it was really minor ok so we
got up to some shuffling and there you
can get rooks off and here the problem
is that f5 is continuous continuous
weakness yeah black will always attack
it with this bishop so that white cannot
just easily win this pawn in the native
stage we see that ok i can get the
bishop over here very actually does
those two things take f5 and keep a two
it's important here that black should
not play the move g6 it's absolutely not
necessary often in order to draw such
simplified endings you want to get ya as
many points as possible of the board I
think here this is a mistake like
shouldn't do that after this wyd retains
minor yeah admittedly minor winning
chances but he has some he has some yeah
maybe like h4 here f 595 and i'll try to
bring the King around and try to win one
of the ports it might not work yeah I
can affect here a force already drawing
yeah you know and this you cannot cannot
continue get in the game they shuffled
forever here it was really slightly
unnecessary rly to do that check I don't
think that this was played actually what
is that it was played I'm sorry huh and
here they agree to a draw yeah black in
this position is just shuttling with
this King and why it has no way White
has no way forward and you cannot go
around to the pawn that say because then
black comes and takes this pawn and yeah
then only only black and win probably
not really able to do so much white has
no chance whatsoever so am a narrow
escape definitely narrow escape in this
game for kayaking he could have easily
easily lost that one I think easily is
wrong but they were yeah he was never in
close to win and really was managed
balancing on the edge there a little bit
okay kiwanis viddler is the final game
to look at for round 13 yeah karana on +
2 + delete swidler still with minimal
very minimal chances if he wins this
game so interesting runo Pez heads with
lies not a golden gai he plays the
classical one with a six yeah the 63
line already had been played in this
event more than once Caruana for example
tried it with white against Aronian in
that game or ever hear played to move a
3 against live on this time he tries a
for a little bit of a different approach
Bishop d7 and c3 mm a relatively modest
looking set up but this is not a bad
choice if you want to play for with ya
keeps many pieces on the board and yet
delays to fight a little bit to later
stage you don't have to fear that
there's some forced line that just
equalize everything um sweetie I now
plays castles certainly not a bad move I
looked at some recent games here and I
thought that 95 was also played this is
something that I actually would probably
like to play in comparison to what Smith
letters because I'm a huge fan of
getting the sea porn some more involved
and get the night away from c6 this is
this kind of configuration is often not
ideal and we see that Swilly gets into
some some issues in the game not because
of this particular position near I'm
just saying that 95 addresses something
that can become a problem and yeah let's
put those moves on the board they look
relatively normal yeah now a five and
after g6 Bishop b3 Bishop to e6 be sure
to a4 and again Bishop 37 they forget
that Spanish regrouping to g3 and around
here it's really a question what is
black doing with his pieces yeah this is
not good it looks at protected squares
and would like to improve but you cannot
paint you can go to e7 like after this
but white is not going to trade and
something like this you really don't
know what to do with your pieces now
there's also d for our blacks position
is a bit crowned only played Bishop g7
that also looks more normal and now aged
three yeah we come to the first critical
position here what should um white play
what should leg play I'm sorry and I
think swidler was a bit fed up with the
maneuvering around yeah it was I'm not
sure this is my interpretation of things
maybe you just overlooked something
when he should play something something
slow rugby 897 something like that what
he played um does not work at all it
seems he went d5 opening up the center
often it's it's kind of a rule in the
Spanish or in the in the Italian game
the black gets in d5 he's usually okay
but then there's this little sentence
behind that he is usually ok unless it's
not and here is not it means like okay
if you can play the file unpunished you
should but here you get punished after
takes takes her 10 in 94 and we see the
problem here then c 5 square is very
very weak and black has problems with
with covering this what should you play
the move f5 and looks immediately dicey
yeah but it is really bad in this case
as 95 is pretty strong there are some
funny lines after 93 check Jay King edge
7 is actually a move because Quincy
three days you form which is in fact
pretty good for white yeah it's quite
funny efore and and here what does 1k
what does my notes say let's check 23
for just Queen d2 now takes Bishop b2
yeah it's a very very funny line of this
is happening just queen age 6 so takes
on oops I screwed up the window here
sorry okay and if this Bishop b2 yeah f5
is just far too loose that's not not
working yea what did he play he played
the move Knight to be 8 tried to trade
the bishops and maybe get the night back
to his heaven like an inner brea
variation
yeah but should be three again back yeah
kawana is always flipping between those
two squares and he had a banner move
forever the move Queen B 3 this would
have been very nice for white the idea
is to play Queen to be seven and if
black takes rook takes the rook also
gets activated here black has some
trouble to play a good move if he plays
the totally normal looking move from
knight c6 then white has a tactic
already push quite nicer takes takes
Jack and here white gets a pawn and the
fantastic position as he has good pieces
sarouk c4 sometimes so knight c6 it's
not flavor in this position Luke a7 is a
bit tougher but this is also not great
as white has besides Bishop h6
immediately also the move d 4 and this
seems to be even better for example
after takes bishop age 6 the vision 86
group deform white has a fantastic
position because of this jay jay yeah
and why the security banner is a pawn up
and has an attack aquino III was very
strong it seems he went back though and
this is not as convincing but still
pretty good um bit should be six now and
this is the next critical moment come on
I'll now place the move Bishop d2 after
long thought it was very tough and he
had a good move available here and move
that we also discussed in the broadcast
the move Knight to c5 it's a bit of a
shame that he didn't do that because it
would have led to very interesting
positions black is more or less for us
to take on c3 yeah you have no other
move Knight c3 96 rupee 6
and then just move the Queen after 95
hoops come on 95 White has the strong
move deform yeah whitey has sacrificed a
pawn but he has an outstanding
compensation yeah I've got lots of space
the bishop pair and attack it's very
nice the Queen the night is on ba de and
how do you play with black that would
have been a very nice position for from
Kara wanna okay play Bishop detour ever
and now Sevilla all of the Sun against
lots of activity he's clearly yeah the
worst is clearly over for him Bishop b3
Queen c7 yeah black has more space here
that's quite nice on the other hand this
whole formation that he has is also a
little bit loose yeah and this is what
karana now tries to ya tries to exploit
by an aggressive move note that he must
win this game if he is not winning he is
yeah very much accepting a situation
where he has to win with black and final
round against kayak and he definitely
wants to win this game or try everything
possible okay age for this is the move
okay it might not be objectively that
brilliant but yeah it leads to the kind
of fight that you want I guess h5
interesting move this is a pawn
sacrifice after a form nighty form
swindler could take this pawn I mean he
did take the pawn and I think white
probably has compensation for this but
not in the way as he plays um I think we
need for also the engine things Queen a
form was probably a try trying to put
the Queen m1c for playing on the light
squares it seems to be roughly
compensation it's maybe not objectively
great but it is definitely a play
opposition with chances especially in
time troll what he played is deform
after Queen c6 now Queen F was not on
and after queen bee three black even at
sea form and here when we were
broadcasting as we thought that Villa
has clearly taken over in this game and
this is really the case after Queen a
form he is better however after 25 rook
a 21 he now plays a totally normal
looking move that turns out to be a
mistake he plays rook 88 just over
protecting ePHI of them banner was Luke
f8 but to just but to see why it's not
so easy after rookie hate kawana now
took only five and in this position had
the move Bishop f4 and the problem is
that here black just has lost upon if he
plays Queen rook takes a form then white
has intending telling this yeah yeah
then white has cleared Jay and rinse the
house here this is the difference to
look f8 if black for example play the
play group f8 here then this whole thing
is completely pointless as rookie for
just wins Jay Knoblauch has broken two
minor pieces and he's got a direct
attack as this is a complete win of
course after look at eight white would
not play this kind of this kind of line
but we see the point rook e8 was just an
unlucky choice yeah now swidler had to
do something like this Queen to be five
and now is in a worse ending yeah those
pawns are weak this Bishop would come
here and they were both in time pressure
and after this we had to move 40 was
yeah
was reached yeah this is forced J and
Bishop before yeah and here when we got
to this ending we were pretty sure that
Cara wanna will win this game the a six
and A six and the c-4 porn are both week
so one of those will drop white has good
control and there was no reason to
believe that sweet level hold in the
game was a rupee five was played and we
come to a critical position pretty soon
that debt got lost that porn a try Kinji
to king of seven and here here's a
critical moment I think even though it's
not so easy to to figure this end game
our turn in the last detail karana
wanted to have a position obviously
we're black takes on g4 maybe I say
maybe it is what the engine gives but
I'm not one hundred percent certain to
trusted him and is to to check and take
here and play the airport that was also
there was also suggested by my
co-commentator and it's actually mean
analyst Grandmaster grown in hearts we
in our broadcast Roland suggested that
this would give more winning chances and
I probably have to agree during the
broadcast I couldn't really determine it
but BBC and we see how this game unfolds
it's easy to say that it probably makes
sense to get another person the H pawn
in fact it's not that dangerous black
quite often even stopped by rogue h7 ham
probably this was giving more chances
okay this is how a koala played and this
takes a long time here to just snatch
the porn back and black managed in the
meanwhile to get the king over and here
we couldn't find a way in the broadcast
at
we couldn't find a way for wide forward
we actually thought that like him just
stayed it was a bit surprising to say
see a little bit later thats villa
actually decided to take on f2 and with
this capture and his trade he allowed
white to get control of the six rank the
point was that after this this porn is
hanging wide of course took covering a
five and now King be Sarah this is
Vilnius idea with King to be seven he
tries to kick the rook out and then get
to the a5 pawn um Kingda three was
played and now Luke age five this is
looks a bit mysterious why didn't he
play King b7 well he could have played
it but I think he was probably a little
bit afraid that in a position like this
white could would go am King you for and
after this King f1 all of a sudden this
rook has no square to keep this Bishop
protected it is however still a draw
because of Bishop before this is
something that sweet i probably could
not calculate till the end otherwise i
think he would have gone for it check
check and here yeah if why doesn't check
then it is very simple or whatever it
doesn't matter hits at all so better is
the check jay king up and now King c5
and this will fall yeah for example here
here Bishop c5 and then black bow take
and make it raw easily yeah that was the
cleanest way to a draw but sweetly
played Luke age five and now c5 yeah now
he is forced to do this king b7 look
back and yeah he cannot allow white
there's those two pawns if they push
further so Bishop f5 which it takes rook
takes and we get this ending yeah to two
rooks
and an extra bishop for white this is
really a notorious ending it occurs
relatively frequently and is well known
to be a draw however it is very
difficult to do in in a limited time
situation this is especially brutal if
you play without an increment the 30
seconds increment helped a lot so that
at least that you can think about every
move but it is very very tricky to
defend we see that swidler jay is
getting to her he plays the so-called
second ranked defense what is the second
ranked defense the rook is on the second
rank and a key idea I just b-roll a
little bit forward one key idea is that
you can often defend with stalemates I
want to say so you're here for example
is this a good moment to show it yeah if
the King comes here for example this
looks critical but like has this move
for stalemates yeah so what it's not
gaining anything he has to go back and
check again so this is the the key
defensive idea from black and descending
it is not have a very tricky because Y
can kind of yeah produce mirror images
on all sides of the ball and you can
easily get totally confused in the game
actually it's wiggler defended this very
well but it turned out to be that i mean
i can analyze that but i don't want to
it's a it's a it's victoriously long
this kind of analysis and maybe
something for a separate video at at one
point and in fact there was one moment
westville actually made a mistake and
then it was a winning position for
Caruana but it was impossible to do in
the remaining moves here look h5 was a
technically speaking a mistake
please ignore the time so they didn't
have that much time left I think Luke h5
here white can win I wish we have to
also wins but the quickest when I just
want to show you how tricky it is his
route should be too threatening made
look h3 and to be ready to cover this
and then Bishop f2 covers against the
check and get some kind of zoosk one
going yeah what is black doing now it's
a yeah it's not easy at all to find a
move look here it's a bishop I up to
that up to him threatening check check
and it goes back again threatening mate
will get 3 jan you know the check now if
black goes up let's root b 7 and here
what is the line 109 gonna move 109 and
it's Ruby sixes the lion king a to check
up ruki to attending check and win no
Bishop e3 and covering this threatening
made and black has no way to defend here
he would need to play King a three check
here for check and checkmate mate let us
actually move 116 and they had the last
trade on move 66 so I think that would
be a draw here because it's exactly a
draw here you will not mistaken maybe
you can correct knew it
I think even if Khurana would
miraculously find the absolute most
precise way to win which is just shown
by a by a table base then I think it's
silly draw because he cannot make it in
the 50 moves um okay so it continued a
little bit more and it was a just from a
theoretical point of view a draw again
and then in fact a win again instead of
Bishop f6 rugby too was at least
technically speaking winning but it was
impossible now by now to make it within
the 50 moves so it's a yeah lots of
drama and jan sangh moves and here they
not agree to a draw because it's 50 move
rewards oh yeah so a very tough game
forum for Kara wanna hear who okay he
was in trouble maybe at one point in the
time trouble face but he had a very good
position very close to winning and
ultimately it is just a draw yeah and
with this we have a situation before the
final round that is in some ways
confusing the confusing thing is that
there's still some importance to the
game on our place anat is one as a half
point behind kayaking and kawana but
with a win can only equalize this course
if they draw and in this case we would
have a three-way time in which kawana
would have the best tiebreaker because
in their mini tournament he has the best
score and those among those three
players if however island it's not
winning and it's a draw between kayaking
and kawana then kayaking is the one who
qualifies for the match because he has
more wins or as you can say if you are a
little bit cynical more losses I'd like
to say yes more losses because I think
this is a ridiculous tirade
and in a way ridiculous i think it's you
can do that but not to decide the World
Championship Challenger anyway that
games that we are going to look at
shortly swidler Anand is of some
importance and okay let's all ever start
with the less important games of the
final round because I want to make this
video also below two hours and the games
were not that interesting actually there
was the game give it to part of this is
actually the game between two players
that have not won a single game giri has
13 drawers and two part of has five
losses in the win they play a Catalan
opening with a quick Knight c3 yeah this
is a bit different than castles um
mostly in regard to this line and I was
a bit surprised that after 95 now this
action interesting on Ford I was a bit
surprised that took part of now played
c5 not that this is particularly bad
it's just that the latest fashion he has
actually queen to d6 played by and by
chronic against Peter Svidler and after
night see for Queen a six in fact black
had a very interesting position in that
game and I thought that would be right
up to par loaves alley and this kind of
position but okay he went c5 this is
more of a solid move with the details c5
being forced Jan now we have an ending
and in this ending white at least has a
symbolic advantage because of the better
bishop on g2 and in the game here we
actually see that this gets traded and i
think the parlor plays very precisely in
the defense okay defenses a bit strong i
mean he's not really worse but he has to
make sure that he gets the bishop out
which he does um him b6 now ready for
training on b7 yeah that got in fact
rated
g5 everything's closed down i already
make a make quick work of this then
nothing much happened in this game yeah
they they repeat it and made an degree
to draw so it was a game we're ready
both sides the only thing would have
been dies for either of them to to to
get a win and but the kind of position
didn't allow for it so tapar off has
probably one of the worst tournaments of
his career with his minus five no win
and it sounds a bit harsh but he even
was a bit lucky he had he had losing
positions against koala two times and
got two draws miraculously and he enemy
was totally lost I mean not just
slightly worse it was something where
the engine is on minus three or things
like that so really bad tournament and
yeah for Gary what can we say 14 draws
anthesis he got much yeah ridicule or
whatever for that but we have to say
that if you look at the pure just to
look at the games he actually played
really well it sounds weird but he was
of all the participants the one he was
never in trouble in not really I mean he
against Ireland Alan could have an
advantage with this rock t4 move as we
saw earlier but this was also clearly
after something Maggie we gambled a
little bit with Bishop f2 other than
that in the let's say early stages of
the tournament or let's say the first 12
rounds he was never worse and he was
winning in some games against Nakamura
against kawana if he wins those two
games he wins the tournament it's just
what it is so Kiku people can love
whatever they want but he did not play
badly he just had two or three games of
her very very dull and then the others
he simply couldn't get the ball over the
line in some way okay and so the next
game to check is
camera Aronian also make relatively
short work of that it was it was
probably quite an interesting game but
it has limits what you can do in a
single video it's error goes in opening
and aronian managed to get in this movie
5 which is one of the goals of this
particular line and it's quite
interesting with if I the c8 Bishop gets
freed and we get very lively piece play
in the center and a key moment comes
after castles where Aronian also now
could have played efore I think that was
an interesting move pushing the night
away to e1 likely and then black places
with a space advantage here on the
kingside can lead to very sharply note
that something like Bishop f5 is
answered with f3 and this is probably
not what black ones yeah it's a if I was
sharp but okay what I Roland did also
it's not leading to boring play he went
Bishop d7 and after the capture only
five white now try to set a center in
motion f-4e for was also possible can
also lead to very sharp play after an
for example rook e8 and now something
like this Bishop c6 and check and now
cool move like Queen to d7 threatening
Queen h3 very nice but white as he 6 and
it's a big mess and so there were a
couple of interesting options even early
on but f-for is not a mandals Bishop f5
kinda attacking yeah now if why it was
afore black is able to take with this so
Queen went up here ruki seven and queen
to be seven so nakamura plays in a very
principled way that becomes now very
tactical Bishop c2 and taking the rogue
it went to see one let's i guess most
obvious move rupee aid queen 86 rugby
too it's a big mess now black is a paw
down but he has owned quite active
pieces and after night 21 taking this
route route p6 queen 85 Bishop e3 i'm
going to be eight I think blacks
activity is sufficient to compensate for
the pawn maybe if you analyze real deep
you find something better but I think
what they plate is making quite some
sense to trade here and now why try to
get the a pawn going it's so ever very
difficult to get to get something
something very substantial the problem
is also that this move this Bishop
before betrayed the bishop it looks like
this is a bad bishop but with the bishop
detour gone the pony 3 gets to be very
very weak and in fact there is nothing
better any more him than to trade
everything off and hear they agreed to a
draw yeah for both players certainly a
tournament that they would probably get
rather want to forget yeah huronian had
a very good start he had a plus to score
the what which was the final score most
of the event um it applies to score
after seven rounds and everything it was
his tournament to take in a way and then
he started to basically yeah fall apart
by losing against on on the very passive
black game that he had and then losing
against william its own yeah he had many
opportunities but didn't didn't take
them yeah nakamura had a bad start yeah
losing that early game against kayaking
babe landed apiece and he never could
yeah come
come back to that it was simply not not
his event he certainly had great
expectations but nothing came out of it
at the end okay the game Sevilla honored
this is still somewhat relevant for the
final standings if Arnold wins this game
then corona actually only needs a draw
with black against kayaking but this is
something that you don't know before
move one you cannot respect you later
Alan's going to win this with black hair
and I can play for a draw with black so
it doesn't it doesn't really work that
way they kayaking and Caruana they had
to play a full game you cannot speculate
or anything here okay um we got again an
English opening and eyelid is sticking
to his bishop before nine really
surprising that he does it again meany
okay here he plays a new move with
rookie aid new move for for him in this
tournament he has played before in that
game against kayaking that he Caruana
sorry against karana that he lost this
is a an idea that he never he didn't try
yet and swidler comes up with the
regrouping interesting regrouping the
night over to see to it now would be one
to try to play on the queenside and we
are actually here on on virgin territory
this has not yet been played this
position I think this is also a reason
why this English opening has gotten this
popularity in this event they yeah
they're simply um yeah I think are some
more tired of playing long theoretical
lines but you have to reproduce things
that you have endless with the computer
all the time here you can get fresher
positions that are not yeah close to a
draw let's say or analyze to some extent
ok d5 so uh non switches to an open
position and I think it makes quite some
sense he is nicely centralized even
though after this we see that he five is
attacked and I was a bit surprised to
see that he now plays the move Bishop
2d6 f6 looked totally normal here and I
didn't think there was a particular
reason to give up the bishop this
position looks fine but he's I mean it's
well known that Ireland has a weakness
for nights and here he just doesn't seem
to care that after d4 takes white is
getting to this bishop pair position
yeah in fact it seems that black is
reasonably solid but but still it was a
bit surprising especially if you keep
into yeah well okay he does not need to
win this game with black we have to be
clear there with the windy can only add
best equalized with the two other guys
but he cannot win the tournament anymore
as his tie break it's too bad um yeah
okay we place Queen to e7 you're hoping
that why it takes on d5 but ok let us
not doing that this is just leading into
black getting this back with a good game
so if all is stronger c5 getting some
space and yeah it looks like a nice
position but he gets some counter player
by this with this better development
that he has all the pieces are
centralized yeah Bishop g5 is a nice
move setting up the straights Joe and
still you think with the bishop pair
white can do something but it's it's
really not much this will the nice move
setting up a blockade on the light
square so that it is some difficult for
white to get anything going here in the
final position and we had this is the
final position after Ruby 6
you can actually argue that maybe maybe
white could continue here it's not yeah
it's not brilliant or anything but you
could think of this Bishop f3 takes and
rook to e1 trying to continue this with
with the two bishops it doesn't feel
like it should net much because whites
pawn structure is a bit worse and yeah
maybe Spiller didn't really want to do
much there he's got a 50-percent score
in the event of course he wanted to
fight for more but now in the final
round I think it's understandable that
you probably don't want to sit there for
ya for for a couple of hours and try to
grind out this ending so a draw a grid
which means that in the absolute key
game of this round between the two
leaders kayaking kawana that kayaking
only needs a draw with white and Caruana
has to win everything else is it's not
enough the reason for this to again
explain it they are on equal points
before the final round both having the
same points in case of the draw we would
have a tie-break system in place the
tiebreak is at first their individual
encounters which would be two drawers in
this case and that means the second time
and would count and this is the number
of wins and kayaking has more wins
because he has won three games and lost
one that game that he lost against
honored so he has three wins against
kiwanis two wins kawada is unbeaten
before the final round and this is this
funny tie-break where it's actually good
if you have lost the game yeah okay you
have won again more but yeah I don't
think it makes any sense I think I don't
understand why they not simply play a
playoff in form of a bunch of rapid
games this would be far more because
it's just Farrah I think then to get
some somewhere
I reckon store in case of the same
number of wins by the way there would
have been this sonneborn bag our system
which is something totally illogical I
don't even want to explain it it's
basically a notary um and yeah so I'm
hugely in favor of those tie breaks for
qualifications spots this kind of thing
to be decided by rapid playoffs okay so
Cameron has to win this we'll see what
happens we see a caesarean in 96 so he
is going for what exactly for this for
the classical disorient this is seen
very rarely in top-level chess as it is
believed to be quite risky for black but
quite risky is exactly the kind of thing
that caruana needs yeah he needs
something that he can fight with and I
think this was a good choice Bishop g5
the so-called rouser system Queen to d2
and castles long this is one of those
old-school Sicilian swear why does
castling long and black ass yeah
counseling short or not at all in fact
after Bishop d7 f4 age 6 was played
mission H form and now be five yeah this
is a super sharp line and yeah what is
the point one point of b5 is the quick
counter play in the center and white um
feels inclined to take on f6 this is
what he did now an important point is
that Queen takes f6 is not good you to
e5 yeah there is this in the position so
so G takes and this is in fact what
black wants in this position he wants
this kind of compact porn center in the
middle
what with this doll upon this kind of
thing this kind of block but he also has
the bishop town and this is a I think
good choice to play for win because you
have that built-in imbalance white in
this position does not want to trade
actually and this is funny yeah you
don't want to trade but you also want to
draw the game and this is a very
difficult game to play because you kind
of always have in the back of your mind
my need to draw or shouldn't I try it
and trading here is usually favoring
black because of his pair of bishops and
the the porn center so I think an
interesting choice here by kawana yeah
what is kayaking doing he plays very
straightforwardly f5 this is in fact the
main strategic idea that white has to
attack those pawns it usually means um
let me phrase it otherwise another way
what black has to avoid yet or course is
to play e5 this kind of thing here
because now why does putting the night
somewhere and now has a fantastic square
here this is a little bit lighter
sveshnikov without any counter player it
just disastrous so white wants to put
pressure on this pawn and black never
wants to move it because he doesn't want
to give up the d5 square so he has to be
very very yeah cautiously in the center
queen to be six is answered by FTC six
and nine takes is six note that just to
show a line if white plays some innocent
move let's say Bishop to e2 then black
just to show the general idea as happy
to play this kind of ending then now
maybe something like h 5 i'm not sure
about the precise move out of it yeah he
has the bishop am and a good center yeah
ideas like before in the right moment
this could be week long term so why does
not want an ending okay II took one c6
and developed it was the main reason for
capturing to get a good Bishop square
age five king be one before 92 and
Quincy five so probably the last two
moves before in 25 were not so precise
by a very weird kind of transposition we
have now reached the position that has
been played in a game funny enough
almost 30 years ago in a game between
the check grandmaster crunch data and
the den kakuzu the biggest expert in the
world of this line 1988 it was now
almost 30 years ago and crunch data
played a very strong move I guess he
played the movie 5 and this is a real
real yeah a real nice attacking move we
can check some possibilities it was not
played by kayaking I can tell you that
right away first easy thing as this is
my next move with Queen D sound so that
is not working ok taking with the pawn
then white has Queen to g5 threatening
Bishop g6 checkmate this leads after
Queen g72 a very strong attack something
like rook f8 rook f1 for example yeah
the bishop has this white has a very
strong attack but this is the best that
black can do in that game casual
actually played five he took with the
Queen and after Brooke age 21 White's
position was very strong even stronger
was to check and after King move rookie
one intending those night loops those
night moves and whites attackers
decisive the movie 5 was very strong
would be interesting to learn y que acha
didn't play it maybe it was due to the
situation in the
in the event when a bad draw was enough
it's also that this a 5ft x cree g5 it
is not totally clear it's not like white
wins but the tech looks quite promising
okay this was played far seventh and a 5
b 3 not enough i expected but it seems
that he wanted to be able to after here
for maybe two to capture and give the
King a little bit of a little bit of
lift I think the position is rockland
roughly equal group she ate and King e7
shielding the pawns black long term as I
said more than once is quite happy his
bishops a center or good but one problem
is definitely there and will not easily
go away the black king is always shaking
in this line it is in the middle of the
board and yeah never really feel very
comfortable yeah Bishop c4 was played
looking at the u6 pawn now I kawana
probably played a risky move Bishop to
e3 but the the move I mean risky is
relative I think it's may be risky if
you think about this in machine terms in
computer terms the computer wants to
play Knight to f4 and just tries to grab
this pawn the thing is that black has
very substantial compensation if we look
at this Bishop d4 for example this is
what the computer is giving 9 like that
and the computer thinks that white is
better well I mean you can argue about
that first of all and I can definitely
assure you that this is not a position
that a human player wants to play and
this is just not not looking good so it
is may be risky ascent in machine terms
but probably a good move in a human game
maybe in general but it is difficult to
assess nowadays I think a human player
would
to play that position with the bishop
coming to d5 ruka 3 is far more normal
yeah we have eight that was covered and
Knight to f4 yeah here um kawana decided
to take on that form it's probably
difficult not to do it so he took it
yeah for example I mean what should like
try if you place a wants to play
something like that then night takes c6
is already a problem jej for us bit
unlucky it's difficult to suggest
something this is also not bad at all
this should f4 Luke f4 point sport takes
was possible was not bad but rook takes
certainly not illogical to keep the
pressure on their farm and now it
forwards played this is actually a move
that I think you could could debate if
this is really great it is opening up
the position a bit which is maybe in
general in black sir yeah something that
black does don't mind but it also um we
can see before porn a bit it wasn't bad
at all probably to just play here and go
for Queen to e5 I think most human
players would prefer Blackie a little
bit and I'm one of those I mean not that
like it's a lot better so what I think
black feels a bit a bit easier to play
them if if you ask me you also know that
an ending for example is good for you
now you can play this in ending play
against those pawns it looks quite
comfortable ok a force play not saying
that it is a mistake but it was
interesting also to delay this yeah now
this position is again quite an
interesting one here kayaking decided to
not yeah stay let's say passive or just
keep the position but
played the movie 5 this is a very
aggressive try and probably yeah
probably it's a it's a good move it's
always very very tough too tough to
assess um what can like do it's always
funny those breakthroughs on squares
that are protected a million times you
have to look at all the captures here
you can quickly discard a couple this is
not working in order to Roxy form the
queen is attack and if it moves away
than 26 wins or in this case teenage
Sammy so this is not working pawn takes
Queen age seven Jack's also I think Jack
Jack pretty easy to check okay that
leaves look cakes and Queen takes Queen
takes there is a surprisingly strong
roots II form attacking this and after
Bishop a group c 7 is very active for
white there's this thread for example
here white is probably better or always
tough to judge but white is probably
better with this activity in the game
look if I force plate by car wanna hear
at first if you look at at the computer
it gives 000 and a draw at first with
this line check and queen age 8 and the
computer gives this and says it's a draw
and so could have a gud ki can have
forced the draw here and no actually not
because black can avoid this draw after
Queen to age 8 by going on with the move
Queen to be five it's quite interesting
ideas to play Queen here and create mail
it's a computer is movement it avoids a
draw black is a pawn off and it's messy
so I think that would have been
yeah very okay with them with Kara wanna
and a possible way of off of this
continuing just to show the type of
position it could happen I know that
doesn't it's not maybe very logical that
Marcia but i just want to show what type
of position like is after like wants to
play this position for example here he
has those three pawns and can do
something in the center or this a porn
is not very dangerous bags construction
is a bit more compact and while this is
not something winning or anything it's
certainly you are not bad at all if you
want to try to win Queen f7 or ever was
not played the move that kayaking plate
is Roxy for attacking the Queen and here
it's difficult yeah what is black
supposed to do if he goes somewhere here
there's just this right so only route d5
is playable now Queen to d2 keeping the
Queen attacked Queen to be six here
black could have played luke t 1 21 and
25 this is actually I think a pretty
solid choice that kawana could have
played he mainly thought that this is
not giving him enough to to play for win
but I think this is something that black
can be quite happy with um in the game
he played Queen to be six I don't think
this is a mistake but see what happens
in the game you know rook h4 so
attacking this rook rookie 523 attacking
on d6 White has a definite that
compensation with voice pawn karana not
found a nice loop Bishop g2 right into
the white camp not playing d5 and
putting this Bishop passive rope to d4
and d5 d6 was saying after all
and our Queen d2 attacking this yeah and
now we come to the deciding decisive
moment of this game and then ultimately
off the event and the question who
challenges some magnus carlsen what Kara
wanna now should have played as prone in
the move Bishop before that Bishop is
hanging after all like this this and
then this position I think here we are
dealing with them probably not equal but
still playable kind of position where
anything could have happened I guess he
played rookie forever and after this
there are only two scenarios black being
hugely better or kayaking finding the
right move and winning the game and he
found a move that wins the game um it's
a yeah if you don't if you have not seen
it you can treat it as an exercise why
to play and win and the move is rook
takes d5 there's also the only move that
is not clearly worse yeah if Black gets
to take here and so on and his Clarion
then the dry then why the scary was yeah
but he can take them it is it is a loop
sack and it works yeah black cannot
decline the sacrifice then what is just
breaking through anyway so take screen
takes why does a rope down but he's
threatening 27 check made and black
actually has no defense yeah absolutely
no defense yeah what can we what can we
look at there is the square f7 it's a
mating square so the black rook here
cannot move white also threatens this
queen d 7 11 can never covered can never
be covered with the rook or Bishop move
so that means that black only has Queen
moves it's just like that and I will
agree move to cover d7 is Queen to c7
yeah and this is not enough because of
20 f5 this was the point yeah looking at
this and keeping this in the position
Black has no defense it's quite quite
funny here for example like rook c8
check check check me it's one of the
mates that is possible here yeah like
black has no defense whatever you try
there's nothing there's nothing
available yeah this was still played by
caruana and white takes ya know if the
King takes teenage seven queen is gone
guys so glad this move but now it's
already made and made it a couple of
moss chick king of eight so I hope she
aided here kawana resigned after King
takes there's check and checkmate mate
yeah so our congratulations on my
congratulations to the challenge of the
world champion now sagi kayaking he won
this event at the end with the plus
three score so the same score that was
some reached I think in in London by
cars in the three years ago plus three
in kayak in case was four wins the four
winds were I think reasonably convincing
yeah he had a very good we had a win
against Nakamura when I camera blundered
a piece but was under pressure the whole
game so a good win for kayaking there he
beat honored in a very nice game he beat
Apollo very convincingly and he won this
game which was of course a battle of
nerves but it was a round equal position
the whole time and then kawana me I
couldn't stand the pressure on whatever
just made a mistake with them with that
perform at the end so nothing to blame
kayaking for he played a good game and
won fair and square so he won four games
he lost one game against Arnold where
get on and played a technical
masterpiece really so I'm also not
really not a big game or something by
kayaking can I can add a couple of
critical situations however where he
could have lost games for sure but he
helped them with this great defensive
skills for example he could have
probably he was close to losing against
Aronian and that was not not the only
case he was also completely lost against
swidler at one point and somehow managed
to save a draw so um yeah it was called
Caruana um I think in some way should
have won the event it's an easy easy to
say that but he had so many
opportunities he should have won against
her part of two times he had to
completely winning positions against him
and yeah this is the full point that's
lacking yeah if he had won those two
games then it could have lost that game
here and yeah it would be very very easy
because then he has so many wins nobody
cares right so hmm he basically spot the
event and not scoring those two wins NTM
had that good position against villa
that he did not convert he had a couple
of chances and of course he also had
critical situations but there was only
one really really critical one way was
lost against giving but okay he somehow
fought that to a 90 moved wrong so at
the end kayaking will challenge magnus
carlsen as it stands probably in New
York not sure if this is really taking
place i mean i'm not i'm not having any
inside information but with the russian
player challenging the world champion it
can always be that some russian sponsor
might be interested in this
um okay i hope you enjoyed the coverage
of this event i made yeah 13 at the end
13 long videos if you have watched all
of them yeah you're very tough cookie
okay i hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching